I'm going to show you one way to do it
there are they pun intended there are
many ways around this circle so I'm
going to show you one of them and maybe
yours looks a little bit different to
mine and that's okay if yours is
different
kamilla I'll have a look because I just
want to make sure just like here that
your logic is watertight that what
you've got is more than just I've worked
out the answer but I've shown what the
answer is because I was different okay
right I gave my first part three I'm
going to do a straight substitution okay
you can see I've got two ways to write
w2 I could choose this one or I could
choose this one okay I'm going to use
the principle argument 1 again you don't
have to do but you'll see why I use it
ok so that one then so that is cause of
etcetera and this is just a straight
substitution so I'm squaring that whole
thing now at this point I have a choice
of what to do right I can multiply this
through like like algebraically that's
how I would do it if I were in
rectangular form but because I'm in
polar form I have another choice right
rather like multiply this by this and
this and then this by listen this I can
use a theorem I know to help me deal
with powers of complex numbers what
their visit I can use democracy right if
you raise a complex number to some power
right what happens to the modulus of
that number it's always good it's also
gonna be raised to that power in this
case the modulus is just 1 right does
that make sense
now by the way if you're gonna invoke
tomorrow's theorem you've got to invert
the whole thing right and so there's the
modulus I know we kind of did state in
the first place but it gets squared to
so don't leave it off what's the other
thing that tomorrow so tell me very good
I multiply the able buying that power
okay so I'm going to have let's see
cause of maybe a 4 PI on 3 because I
doubled it plus I sine
you okay with that now just like
Pythagoras is here right you quoted
something there's a reason so I'm gonna
say along the ante by two waters there
okay now remember it's proof so what am
I gonna do you know where we're going
but you know we're going so that one
square that's just going to disappear
the way that I've chosen to prove the
next bit is that did you remember I
don't I hope you guys remember actually
last year when I came around and I came
to your new meeting sometimes and I'd
say oh if you're going to choose to you
you're gonna choose extension one you
need to know these things right what are
the things I always single out is
trigonometry trigonometry is a big deal
into unit and extension one and
extension to right you just have to know
these kinds of properties like like that
because they form an integral part of
all of these higher work in strength I'm
going to use another property of the
trig functions to get me from key on to
there right that's where I'm going
what's the relationship between this and
this one how are they related they are
one full period apart on the side and
cause curse do you agree with that
because pepper far is that what is a
full period it's two pi right so what
I'm gonna do is another lease rights
anymore it's just one I'm going to say
well cause of some angle right he's the
same as that angle +25 right because
cosine is periodic every 2 pi radius
where you get you find a whole pie oh so
you can buy whatever you like it's the
same deal with sign it has the same
period like that do you see what I've
done okay
are we to the fact that cos and sine are
periodic functions
okay I've made the change I said why and
now I just just evaluate the numbers
right this is just going to beat you
pine on three and so is this
no that's one space so I'll say tied up
together in a nice neat bow okay are you
happy with that